[Music]
the SNP is gathering for its autumn
conference in Glasgow today there are
reports that they could be about to
throw their weight behind a second
brexit referendum but with a significant
so joining us now is the party's leader
in Westminster in Blackford thank you
very much for being with us on the show
today
good morning Sophie now you've said that
the SNP could potentially support a
second referendum on breakfast if there
are guarantees around a second Scottish
independence referendum I mean that
sounds a bit like an ultimatum surely
brexit is too important to play politics
with well we're not playing politics
with Wrexham because you're right is too
important because it's about jobs it's
about prosperity and we know if there's
a hard break set if we don't with the
single market and the customs union
there's a very real threat to jobs in
Scotland and indeed throughout the rest
of the United Kingdom Fraser davender
have told us that there's a threat to
80,000 jobs in Scotland people on
average will be 2,300 pounds a year
worse off through a hard breakfast so
one of the things we are seeking to do
is to say to the Prime Minister that you
must keep us in the single market in the
customs union people didn't vote to
become pure and that's our first
objective and everything that we're
doing today I firmly believe that there
is a majority in the House of Commons to
stay in the single market the customs
union and first and foremost we must
make sure that that is on the agenda but
we're also making it clear to the Prime
Minister that we will not support
measures that take us out of the single
market in the customs union that will
mean that people are at threat to losing
their jobs and the livelihoods as a
consequence of that but it's also to
remind the prime minister that we were
told in our own referendum in 2014 that
if Scotland stayed within the United
Kingdom that our place and unit would be
secured now of course in the 2016
referendum Scotland overwhelmingly voted
to stay within the EU by 62 to 38
percent we can't be dragged out of the
single market a customs union against
our will and what we are saying is if
there is to be a people's vote then we
need to make sure that our position is
protected we must have the right that if
we are being dragged out of Europe that
were being dried out the single market
and the customs union that we have that
ability to determine our own future and
of course
as this conference takes place there was
a huge demonstration yesterday in
Edinburgh talking about two hundred
thousand people that marched in support
for Scottish independence that are pulls
out this morning that sure that a
majority of the Scottish people would
support an independent Scotland and a
likelihood of a of a harbor access so
it's very clear that circumstances here
are changing I think people are
expressing a very clean opinion that
they want to have their rights as
European citizens protected commune
completely to that over the coming
months let me just get clear that and
because you're clearly saying there that
you want to see at the UK remaining as
part of the single market I mean that as
far as I'm aware is effectively off the
table when it comes to the brett said
that tourism a is trying to negotiate so
if the UK leaves a single market as
expected are you saying that you would
then support a second referendum well
what I am saying is that all our efforts
in the short term will be about staying
in the single market in the customs
union I don't accept this off the table
I do believe that there's a majority in
the House of Commons for that and I
would say to each and every MP and
appeal to every MP that be aware of what
you're voting for when it comes to that
meaningful vote are you prepared to look
at your own constituents and make them
pure as a consequence of this now I'll
be going to see Michele Barney here on
25th of October I'll be going with other
party leaders I'll be going with Vince
Cable with the Greens and with Mike
Emery and we'll be making that point
that we must make sure that we put that
proposition of staying in the single
mark and the customs union strong and
I'll be appealing to labour and
conservative MPs to join that as well
Theresa May as suffering from the fact
that she has beholden to her right-wing
brexit ears in their own party
she should govern in the interest of all
in the United Kingdom and not simply
dance to the tune of her brexit ears and
recognized that the best interest of
everybody and I was staying in the
single market and the customs union no
look hypothetically if we're not in a
position that we can achieve that then
all options will be on the table
we haven't been arguing for a peoples
vote but we'll make it very clear if
there is to be such a thing that
Scotland's position must be protected we
will not and cannot be dragged out of
the single market and the customs union
against our will there's an expressed
view and will of the Scottish people to
stay in what we've been talking a lot
about the situation in Northern Ireland
and there has been a lot of
speculation about you know bespoke
agreement for Northern Ireland where
perhaps at northern island remains in
the customs union or with better access
for single market I mean is that
something you could envisage happening
for Scotland absolutely I mean if we're
saying that there has to be a bespoke
deal for Northern Ireland then let me be
absolutely clear we must all do
everything that we can to support the
delivery of the Good Friday Agreement
nothing that should happen out to brakes
it should impair all the Good Friday
Agreement but if it means that there's a
bespoke deal for Northern Ireland there
is no reason why the Prime Minister
shouldn't be looking at putting the same
circumstances on the table for stop we
have a crate from from you as well on
these this idea of a second independence
referendum because I know it's something
of course that many SNP supporters would
like to see now Nicola Sturgeon is yet
to set out a timetable for that
happening if it is to happen in the
future and can you give us any guidance
on when we're likely to know how plans
and when you can see a second referendum
have happening if it happens at all well
what we have said is let's see what's
going to happen with the brexit process
first where we know what the outcome of
brexit is going to be then we'll reflect
on what the options are for Scotland but
I would remind everyone that in the 2016
Scottish election the SNP won that
election with a manifesto commitment
there if there were no material changes
circumstances that they were reserve the
right to call an independence referendum
so that's a manifesto still stands and
if the circumstances are right then of
course the First Minister will reflect
on that and the options of there are for
the Scottish people but one of the
things that we need to do over the
coming weeks and months is talking about
why Scotland should be independent the
fact that we want to deliver a
prosperous and a fairer country take
Scotland away from the chaos that is
brexit and sure that we can have a
country that we can all be proud of that
can be a destination in Europe so we'll
concentrate on that and at the same time
when it comes to the point that we know
the brexit destination then we can have
that discussion with the people of
Scotland okay in Blackfoot thank you
very much